hello everyone my name is karthika Rajan
I'm a Solutions Architect with Google
cloud platform so I'm gonna talk about
cloud memory store for Redis as well as
open census today first cloud memories
short for Redis it provides a fully
managed in-memory datastore service
that's built on scalable secure and
highly available infrastructure that's
managed by Google now caching capability
as most of you know is extremely
important for most production
applications and latency goes
hand-in-hand with caching the way most
people reduce latency is using caching
now tracing this latency in an
end-to-end fashion for your application
is the role of observability and it
helps you design your application faster
and it will also help you diagnose
issues faster now I should point out
that cloud memory store for Redis
already has powerful monitoring
capabilities built in but this is
entirely on the server side in this
video what we'll look at is how you can
build observability of attributes like
end-to-end latency directly into your
applications with something called open
census Open census is a vendor agnostic
set of libraries that provide symmetric
collection as well as tracing
capabilities so before we get to our
demo let's look at the application
architecture our application is a simple
three-tier application and it's hosted
on google kubernetes engine at its core
it consists of a simple java spring boot
application and users interact with this
application via GCPs
HTTP load balancer and for the database
tier our application uses cloud sequel
specifically the my sequel engine in
cloud sequel when the user issues a
query against our application the
results returned from the database are
cached using cloud memory store for
Redis with that context let's see the
demo in action so in this application
what we'll do is we will look for our
employees in our directory by typing in
part of their name in this case we'll
type in Mel and we see that a whole
bunch of results are returned
in addition to those results we also see
that the application tells us how long
that query took 248 milliseconds in this
case now let's try that query again I'll
type in Mel again and as you can see now
it only took one millisecond that's
because the results were cached in cloud
memory store for Redis let's dive a
little deeper into it by looking at what
open census tracing tells us we've
configured open census to perform trace
logging into cloud trace which is a
service offered by Google cloud platform
navigating to cloud trace we can see
that our trace logs are easily
identifiable by the name of the function
that we used and in this case it also
tells us how long the overall function
took 248 milliseconds approximately open
census tracing also lets us dive deeper
into our overall function call you can
see here that our application attempted
to get the results from the cache in
this case cloud memories drawer for
Redis did not find it in the cache hence
the request to my sequel down below you
can see that my sequel took
approximately two hundred forty-four
milliseconds about twice the order of
magnitude that it would take to fetch
the data from Redis we can also see here
that we have annotated cache misses to
help us better trace our application
diving a little deeper into what happens
after our results were fetched from my
sequel you can see that our application
added the results to the cache using add
to cache what about the second time the
query is issued we expect the results to
be fetched from the cache and that's
what we see using open census tracing we
can see that this query took a lot less
time around one millisecond because the
results were found in the cache it did
not have to access the database and we
saved approximately 240 milliseconds
that's quite a bit of time so that was
the happy path you can see how we also
have library level tracing here ok now
let's see how open census can help us
diagnose issues that occur what we'll do
here is we'll simulate a network issue
where we cannot reach our Redis host and
we'll type in the name Mel again while
we expect this to take a lot less time
because we expect there was
to be in the cash we see that it
actually takes 240 milliseconds or so so
there's something wrong with our
application there's too much latency so
let's go back to open census tracing and
look for the most recent request diving
deeper into it we see that there was a
cache miss and the reason for the cache
miss is that our application was unable
to connect to Redis now in production we
would have to chase this error down and
it would be a lot more difficult to find
the error without this tracing
capability now we know that it's a
network issue or some kind of
connectivity issue getting to cloud
memory store for Redis and we know where
to focus our efforts so that can save us
a lot of time during diagnosis hopefully
that gives you an idea of how you can
use open census for both improving
performance as well as diagnosing issues
to summarize we looked at how you can
use cloud memory store for Redis to
significantly reduce latency in your
application following that we also saw
how you can build in and end
observability directly into your
application using open census if you're
interested in using open census in your
application please visit open census I
uh so thank you for watching if you
enjoyed this video please click the like
button and subscribe to this channel
[Music]